[Music]
his vitals are dropping we're losing him
we really want to upload we could be
together forever you're so amazing but
forever is just like Oh up looks that
way Oh ours the other way what do you
want to do three to upload
hello innocence ten fingers and toes
pretty seamless this is the first day of
the rest of your afterlife welcome to
Lake View lets you use timeless
Americana no it's not even real food
okay this one do I dare dare you
boundaries to you
denied in-app purchase required this is
what you look like for real you're not
some old dude or something no this is me
real cutie so I understand you're in a
bad place yesterday ah it's only weird
if you make it weird
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh there's a guy named Lincoln to do
he's in computers you know you can walk
on water whenever you want no way I'm
not even supposed to be here nobody
feels like they should be here you think
I wanted to fall into the Grand Canyon
that's how you died they should expect
people to try and break the glass floor
I saw that video you dabbed on the way
down that's how you get the lights
[Music]
[Music]